I like it here it makes me a peaceful we  do you're not from around here are you  good time what was your job  that was unless you know business as you  know we manage the investments of our  employees if a former agent dies after  retirement we're eight million dollars  goes back to the company this is a bad  idea okay  somebody set me up over here crazy you  have nothing to do with it you start to  kill the black heist and kidnaps cute  little neighbors  we should payments that we don't have to  look over our shoulder for the rest of  our lives  you'll need all of it try not to be  scared you make mistakes when you're  afraid thought you stopped smoking  figured it wouldn't kill me  why are you doing this I like it  you're not a good man you're doing a  good thing  did you happen to see anything peculiar  at the past couple days  No  you